la ville de Lyon a une relation très
spéciale avec le train point de passage
obligé entre nord et le sud du continent
européen Lyon a accueilli la deuxième
ligne de chemin de fer française des
1832 et on n'a jamais cessé depuis de
modifier et repenser les nombreuses
gardes la ville le train a structuré la
ville guider l'aménagement et contribuer
à de grandes évolutions aujourd'hui
patrimoine ferroviaire a un rôle
primordial à jouer dans les mobilités
durables à Lyon la rénovation des gares
et le symbole de la transformation
urbaine et des enjeux actuels
bonjour à tous bienvenue à Lyon pour
cette vidéo réalisée à l'occasion des
Journées européennes du patrimoine 2022
elle se déroule partout en France ce
week-end les 17 et 18 septembre et elles
ont pour thème cette année le patrimoine
durable grâce au soutien de la SNCF on
va découvrir ensemble patrimoine
ferroviaire de la ville de Lyon qui en
dit beaucoup sur la manière dont on
pense les villes depuis 200 ans je serai
accompagné de trois spécialistes qui
vont tout nous expliquer mais avant les
visites je vous donne quelques éléments
de contexte si vous êtes déjà venu à
Lyon peut-être que vous êtes rendu
compte que c'est une ville très
contrainte géographiquement il y a deux
cours d'eau la Saône et le Rhône et deux
collines celle de Fourvière et celle de
Croix-Rousse en un mot bah c'est
compliqué l'aménagement urbain à Lyon
le chemin de fer qui arrive à Lyon en
1832 depuis Saint-Étienne doit trouver
de l'espace pour s'implanter le site de
Perrache donc le sud de la presqu'île a
les trois entre Saône et Rhône et
choisis pour accueillir un débarcadère
provisoire pour décharger le charbon un
véritable bâtiment est construit en 1845
quand on réalise que le train n'est pas
qu'une invention sans lendemain dans le
même temps le projet de la ligne Paris -
Marseille vient s'inviter dans
l'aménagement lyonnais donc on
s'interroge sur l'emplacement des
futures voies et de la gare pour les
passagers depuis Paris faut-il percer
Fourvière pour arriver à Perrache où
faut-il percer la Croix-Rousse pour
arriver dans la plaine là où la place ne
manque pas le débat est tranché par le
gouvernement parisien la gare lyonnaise
sera à Perrache et une nouvelle gare est
inaugurée en 1856 l'année suivante en 57
les différentes compagnies de chemins de
fer celles de Saint-Étienne de Paris
Lyon et de Lyon Méditerranée sont
fusionnés pour former la Paris Lyon
Méditerranée l'ancêtre de la SNCF dont
la gare Perrache est désormais l'une les
clés de voûte vous avez les bases
maintenant on peut y aller
on commence par Perrache je retrouve
Louis baldasseroni maître de conférence
à l'Université de Nîmes qui va donc nous
présenter la gare
quand on est Lionel lyonnaise ce qui est
mon cas
il y a 10 ans on n'allait jamais de ce
côté-là de la ville parce qu'il y avait
pierre
renforce une coupure qui était déjà là
au 18e siècle c'est des marais c'est par
la suite un espace où il y a beaucoup
d'activités industrielles et d'entrepôt
c'est pas vraiment là le centre de la
vie de la cité et il y a 110 ans on
habitait pas tellement de ce côté-là de
la ville puisque c'était réservé aux
activités industrielles et commerciales
là typiquement donc la gare là où on est
occupe un espace assez vaste et ce qui
va avec et avec l'exploitation du chemin
de fer dès le début c'est l'achat par
les entrepreneurs de la compagnie de
chemin de fer les frères Seguin de 28
hectares de terrain à destination
principalement d'entrepôt pour les
industriels donc il y a toute une
opération immobilière en fait derrière
et 28 hectares on n'aurait pas pu les
trouver autour de la place Bellecour au
début du 19e est-ce qu'on peut justement
aller voir un détail de partie ancienne
de la gare le bâtiment voyageur que
qu'on va voir juste après c'est alors
d'après les architectes un des plus
beaux témoignages de l'architecte Alexis
Sandrier l'architecte qui a conçu
plusieurs gares au milieu du 19e bon la
marquise tout à fait 19ème avec son
acier Boulonnais et puis et puis son
verre translucides c'est tout à fait
classique de l'architecture de l'époque
et puis c'est le même principe la même
combinaison de matériaux qui se
retrouvent à l'intérieur dans la halle
tu vois au fronton de chacun de ces de
ces bâtiments on a des sculptures des
blasons de ville qui sont traversées par
des lignes ferroviaires au départ de
Perrache donc en gros tu es arrivé de la
place Bellecourt avait la perspective
droit sur le l'entrée de la de la halle
du bâtiment voyageur et puis les deux
ailes de chaque côté et toi tu trouves
que l'architecture imaginait dans les
années 70 c'est logique disons qu'en
fait chaque époque à sa logique autant
on voit bien la différence entre la
logique milieu 19e ou tout devait être
vraiment à niveau pour le voyageur donc
qui avait un parcours assez assez
linéaire dans le sens où il avait pas
forcément des étages à parcourir pour
aller d'un espace à un autre et par
contre dans les années 70 on est
beaucoup plus dans ce qu'on appelle en
architecture le fonctionnalisme
typiquement le principe de faire
l'autoroute en dessous puis les
transports en commun puis les
circulations piétonnes puis les
commerces voilà en millefeuille au
milieu du 19e siècle Lyon a donc une
gare flambe en neuve mais qui ne résout
pas tous les problèmes logistiques loin
de là les trains sont allés 3 et de plus
en plus d'activités sont délocalisées de
l'autre côté du Rhône là où il y a
davantage de place on construit de
nouvelles gares pour décharger les
marchandises ou les voyageurs ce sont
les gardes et Brotteaux de la
Guillotière ou encore celle de la
Part-Dieu promise à un grand avenir
maintenant direction la gare de la
Part-Dieu on va rencontrer Etienne
Faugier qui est maître de conférences à
l'université Lyon 2 et historien le but
c'est d'ouvrir depuis depuis l'arrêt
depuis votre train vous voyez Lyon en
fait donc ce qui les travaux qui ont été
faits avant il y avait un hôtel ça a été
enlevé pour justement ouvrir la garde
des deux côtés à la fois du côté lion et
de voir tout ce qui nous attend ce qui
nous attend voilà effectivement et
surtout Fourvière donc tu vas voir cette
perspective de dire on est à Lyon
Fourvière c'est le symbole de Lyon et de
l'autre côté d'ouvrir sur les nouveaux
quartiers qui sont en train d'être
dynamisés en particulier donc c'est
aussi pensé par la SNCF comme étant un
lieu de vie
pourquoi on construit par Dieu alors
qu'il y a plein de gares à Lyon il y a
les Brotteaux à côté on a vu Perrache
pourquoi on a besoin d'une nouvelle gare
on a besoin d'une nouvelle guerre parce
que la presqu'île est complètement
approprié par le bâti et notamment le
bâti ancien et le patrimoine donc c'est
assez important donc on protège ce
patrimoine et pour la carte des protos
on voit que c'est un bâtiment qui est
riche d'un point de vue architectural
d'un point de vue artistique et qui au
final et d'entouré de bâtiments et donc
elle elle est aussi un peu contrainte
pas les tendre va ajouter des voix
élargissement on peut ajouter des
situer déjà on ne peut pas rajouter plus
de vent on peut pas étendre la gare
comme on va comment on va le voir là
pour la guerre de la Part-Dieu qui peut
s'étendre en longueur en largeur et qui
va pouvoir aussi accueillir davantage de
voix notamment les voix TGV parce que
c'est vraiment le TGV qui qui motive la
construction de la Part-Dieu alors c'est
pas seulement de TGV c'est le fait que
le quartier va être aménagé avec de la
bibliothèque de la Part-Dieu avec le
centre commercial avec l'auditorium des
années 70 70 75 un des projets de la
Part-Dieu aussi c'est sans doute un peu
mais c'est aussi de relier Paris à
Marseille effectivement le Paris Lyon
Marseille est une ligne toute droite
donc permet d'aller plus rapidement et
de fait comme je disais avec le centre
commercial avec voilà c'est
fonctionnalités que va accueillir ce
nouveau quartier une gare et la
bienvenue pour pouvoir développer
d'autres activités et c'est pour ça que
aujourd'hui la gare de Lyon Part-Dieu
accueille davantage de voyageurs que la
garde de Perrache donc
il y a plus de plus de 100000 voyageurs
alors qu'à l'époque c'était en 1983
quand tu as une inauguré c'est à peu
près 35000 ça ne fait que augmenter
c'est un peu le malheur de la réussite
en fait c'est que plus on met des
infrastructures plus les gens les
utilisent et donc oui les travaux qui
sont en cours là actuellement de votre
point de vue ils sont pertinents sont à
nos modes de vie actuelle ou alors il y
a plusieurs réponses alors effectivement
ça répond dans la à mesure où on va
développer
le patrimoine durable avec cette offre
de mobilité on parle plus vraiment de
transport on parle de mobilité puisque
on va agréger tous les modes et c'est ce
qui permet d'avoir autant de monde à un
endroit puisque le métro va déposer tous
ses voyageurs les trains vont les
reprendre ou les déposer et donc on
rayonne comme ça de ce côté-là
auparavant encore aujourd'hui vous avez
l'automobile qui passe qui peut circuler
dorénavant elle ne passera que dans le
tunnel de du boulevard vie et merle
c'est une influence qui vient enfin on a
des influences d'autres pays ou si les
influences effectivement états-uniennes
notamment avec ce qu'on appelle le Toad
le trafic orienté de distribution on
redistribue le trafic à partir des gares
et on travaille en fait ce qu'on appelle
la rupture de charge en termes de mode
de transport c'est à dire comment on
passe d'un mode à l'autre parce
qu'aujourd'hui n'importe lequel d'entre
vous utilise plusieurs modes dans sa
journée parler des influences notamment
du côté des États-Unis on a déjà des des
bilans un peu on voit si ça fonctionne
ou pas
les travaux de de chercheurs en
urbanisme on aménagement du territoire
en géographie montre que c'est toujours
compliqué de modifier un flux les
voyageurs quand ce qu'ils veulent c'est
absolument aller du point A au point B
le plus rapidement possible avec le
moins de souci possible moins de monter
de descendre de dos d'âne de voilà de en
toute sécurité aujourd'hui vous allez de
plein pied vous pouvez même rentrer
votre vélo sans avoir le porter vous
verrez sans avoir les porter donc tout
ça c'est fait pour penser à un
déplacement sur souple facile et
agréable
concernant les Journées européennes du
patrimoine qu'est-ce qui est proposé au
public là ce weekend alors ce qui est
proposé c'est une visite alors plus
largement pas seulement de la gare de la
Part-Dieu parce qu'elle par rapport à
Perrache qui est un monument en soi la
garde la Part-Dieu est finalement pas si
emblématique d'un point de vue
architectural pas donc on visite un
quartier autour de tout l'ensemble que
qui est le quartier de la Part-Dieu qui
est notamment l'oeuvre d'un architecte
Charles delfente qui a fait pas mal
d'éléments comme justement l'auditorium
la bibliothèque le centre commercial
enfin une gare c'est un lieu parfait
d'expérimentation et ça peut être un
symbole pour une ville une adaptation à
un changement de voix changement d'air
c'est clairement pour ça que la guerre
de la Part-Dieu se fait vitrine du
développement durable avec cette taxant
sur les modes doux les gars sont des
lieux expérimentation mettre des
expositions artistiques ça se fait aussi
dans des gares on n'aurait jamais
imaginé dans les années 50-60 que la
guerre pour être un lieu culturel mais
pas seulement par de l'histoire et par
culturelles ponctuelle qui permet aux
gens de s'approprier la garde de prendre
en photo il y en a une heure ou à un
moment où on est tous instagrammable et
voilà ça aide aussi à prendre part et à
prendre corps dans la gare et dans ces
lieux
en parallèle de se déplacement du centre
ferroviaire de Perrache vers Dieu il y a
un grand changement qui survient à Lyon
j'ai nommé l'arrivée de l'autoroute en
plein centre-ville le site choisi dans
les années 70 pour rattacher lassis à la
7 et donc relier une fois de plus Paris
à Marseille n'est autre que le quartier
de Perrache cette décision prise par des
gens pourtant en pleine possession de
leur facultés intellectuelle transforme
alors le cours de Verdun un large
boulevard arboré en un énorme échangeur
autoroutier une barrière de 120 mètres
de large coupant totalement la
circulation dans le quartier et masque
en complètement la gare sans parler de
la pollution atmosphérique à Lyon on a
pris l'habitude de l'appeler le plat de
nouilles parce que vu du ciel pas besoin
de vous expliquer pourquoi
aujourd'hui ça paraît complètement
aberrant de faire passer une autoroute
dans un centre-ville pourquoi dans les
années 70 ça posait pas de problème ce
qui qu'est-ce qui a fait qu'on a adhéré
à ce projet alors que ça a plein
d'inconvénients
effectivement du point de vue riverain
et nuisances sonores pollution de l'air
etc et ça dans les années 60-70 on en a
un petit peu conscience d'où justement
l'idée du tunnel de Fourvière finalement
de faire passer l'autoroute en tunnel
donc c'est finalement la solution la
plus pragmatique qui a été choisie c'est
quoi les projets justement pour ce
quartier donc ce qui a été choisi c'est
dans le cadre du projet ouvrant Perrache
c'est finalement plutôt d'agrandir les
ouvertures ou du moins de les clarifier
pour qu'on puisse davantage passer du
nord au sud de Perrache notamment avec
des cheminements piétons
on l'a compris suppression du plat de
nouilles passerelle traversant le pôle
multimodal le tout avec une bonne dose
de végétalisation de quoi respirer
davantage et enfin changer de siècle par
Dieu aussi se transforme en ce moment
avec pour objectif de fluidifier les
déplacements et de s'intégrer au mieux
dans ce quartier extrêmement fréquenté
centre névralgique de quartier en
transition ces deux gares incarnent la
transformation à l'oeuvre le changement
de voix et quand on parle de train pour
changer de voix il faut un aiguillage on
termine cette vidéo avec la visite du
poste d'aiguillages 1 de Perrache
remarquable pour son histoire et son
architecture et qui symbolise à lui seul
les mutations dont on a parlé avec ses
28 mètres de haut et ses allures de
phares dressés au-dessus de la Saône il
veille sur les rails depuis bientôt 100
ans désaffecté en 2016 il a trouvé
depuis peu une nouvelle vocation et
c'est avec Olivier Velay architecte du
patrimoine qu'on va découvrir tout ça
on y va
je dois être un peu en c'est une faute
contrôle
pendant 86 ans alors il a été modernisé
dans les années 50 de manière assez
importante puis la fin en 2016 et ce
poste il a pas été démantelé en général
il pose d'aiguillages ils sont
démantelés quand en fin de vie ici ne
l'a pas été puisqu'il fait partie d'un
programme de préservation qui s'appelle
post remarquable objectif étant de
protéger en fait 28 postes d'aiguillages
partout en France ils ont tous une
technologie différente moi justement
quand j'ai préparé la vidéo ce qui m'a
paru fou c'est qu'il a été en service ce
poste jusqu'en 2016 alors que quand on
le voit on se demande comment il a pas
pu être en conflit avec les nouvelles
technologies justement il a pas été
obsolète avant obsolète
non puisqu'il était encore en emploi
mais effectivement une technologie il
était tout à fait dépassé c'est certain
toutes les logiques de sécurité elle
date du début du 20e siècle en général
avec l'invention le développement de
l'électricité donc un poste ici des
années 30 il était déjà assez sûr à sa
sortie puis il a été modernisé au début
des années 50 donc il a un très bon
niveau de sécurité le travail de
l'aiguilleur ça consiste en quoi ça
consiste à assurer la sécurité des voies
il faut surtout qu'il protège
les personnes quand il y a des travaux
les biens d'une manière générale et puis
ensuite le métier de l'aiguilleur
derrière c'est gérer les conflits donc
c'est plutôt ça parce que aiguiller le
bon train en bonne endroit c'est pas
très compliqué c'est assez rapide par
contre connaître sa gare savoir prendre
les bonnes décisions au bon moment c'est
je pense à ça qu'on reconnaît un bon
aiguilleur c'est celui qui est efficace
quand il y a un défaut pour ne pas créer
des retards supplémentaires
c'est pourquoi c'est quoi une aiguille
alors l'aiguille c'est la partie mobile
de l'aiguillage
quoi c'est vraiment le y a l'aiguillages
c'est l'appareil de voix entier
l'aiguille c'est uniquement la partie
mobile qui va permettre au train d'aller
à gauche ou à droite donc l'aiguille ça
fait ça fait 2 mètres
[Applaudissements]
par exemple il avait cette machine là
décidé le positionnement des aiguilles
en fait ici l'idée c'est que chaque
poignée correspond à un itinéraire d'où
le nom poste à levier d'itinéraire et un
itinéraire c'est l'ensemble des
appareils de voix donc des aiguillages
entre deux points je vais vous expliquer
AP c'est arrivé de Paris DP c'est
direction Paris on peut avec ces
poignets relier tous les points de
gauche au point de droite ou les points
de droite ou point de gauche vous pouvez
appuyer sur la [ __ ] en bas
voilà là vous pouvez tirer sur la
poignée vous pouvez tirer assez fort
voilà il s'est allumé en blanc
et ensuite quand vous allez arriver au
dernier cran donc il va il va franchir
le signal et on va le voir circuler sur
l'itinéraire qui a été tracé pour lui en
simuler on est d'accord que ce train
n'existe pas voilà
ce serait bien pratique mais ça serait
un peu inquiétant et journée du
patrimoine les gens ils peuvent venir
justement
on est en train de remettre en service
ce poste d'aiguillage donc de manière
simulée donc il y a tout un logiciel
informatique qui s'est rajouté par
dessus sur la partie électromécanique
mais effectivement l'idée c'est que ça
soit les gens qui fasse que vous avez
fait
avant de partir Olivier Velay a tenu à
nous montrer le local technique situé
juste en dessous au troisième étage du
poste
on est dessous
poignées donc quand je tourne ou je tire
la poignée c'était c'est parti là que je
faisais bouger et effectivement après
derrière on a dessus des mécanismes des
commutateurs se des grosses
interrupteurs qui servent à transformer
les signaux mécaniques en signaux
électriques et après tous les boîtiers
que vous avez autour de vous c'est tout
ce qui est finalement
lieu et oreille du poste pour savoir où
sont les trains justement si tu as
l'aiguille est à gauche ou si tu as
l'aiguille est à droite et le nombre
oui c'est beaucoup
c'est beaucoup c'est beaucoup de câbles
mais bon petit à petit on en vient à
bout les postes des grandes gardes ces
années-là était comme ça
et après
en fait c'est parce que j'aime beaucoup
l'ambiance
ça a une certaine beauté oui
vous voyez par exemple qui a les
macarons en images à côté de votre
persil
il y a des tas de petits détails qui ont
une certaine élégance ou même les ça
aussi c'est une certaine élégance que
c'est souvent c'est voilà c'est
relativement bien écrit il y a plein de
détails qui ont une certaine beauté à
désuetes
conserver ces sites industriels qui ont
fait la ville tout en repensant leur
usage en un mot c'est vrai pour une
ville plus durable j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu samedi et dimanche à
l'occasion des Journées européennes du
patrimoine des visites en petits groupes
sont prévues dans les trois lieux que
nous venons de voir il suffit simplement
de vous inscrire sur affluence.com je
vous conseille également d'aller sur le
site
patrimoine.sncf.com pour connaître le
programme de ces journées je vous mets
toutes les infos dans la barre de
description et ici dans le petit i je
vous remercie d'avoir regardé cette
vidéo et je vous dis à très vite salut